keanu reeves career stretches right back
into the 1980s
and well let's just say he's had his
fair share of ups and downs
from killer action flicks and
heartwarming dramas to tacky thrillers
and cheap sci-fi
these are the best and worst keanu
reeves movies
everyone knows that a dog is a man's
best friend so when a group of russian
gangsters break into john wick's home
kill his puppy and drive off in his car
he does what any notorious assassin
would do he makes it his mission to hunt
these men down and destroy them
but make no mistake john wick is more
than just a montage of mindless fight
scenes
the cinematography is striking the
pacing will keep you hooked and the
world building is genuinely intriguing
on top of that reeves performance as a
man haunted by grief and loss is
absolutely top notch and it doesn't
exactly hurt that he nails the action
sequences either
so far the original film has spawned two
sequels john wick chapter 2 and john
wick chapter 3 parabellum
both movies have earned positive
receptions from critics and audiences
and the story is even set to continue in
may 2022 with another installment john
wake chapter 4.
yeah i'm thinking i'm back
and for the record every single film on
the franchise so far really has been
amazing so if you want to see reeves as
action star best
this is the place to start in the iffy
romantic crime thriller siberia reeve
stars is lucas hill
an american diamond merchant who lands
himself in trouble after traveling to
russia to sell a rare variety of blue
diamonds to the gangster boris volkov
it kinda seems like lucas should have
anticipated that this transaction
wouldn't work out in his favor
and sure enough when he arrives he finds
that his contact with the diamonds has
disappeared
now lucas is desperate to track him down
before boris comes looking for what he's
owed
you'd be forgiven for assuming that a
film involving a diamond heist and a
forbidden romance would bring a little
more excitement to the screen than
siberia does
but sadly this movie's plot is kind of
plotting and dull but what makes siberia
so frustrating is how seriously this
film takes itself
you can't even look at it as the kind of
movie that's so bad that it's actually
good
much like an actual trek through siberia
the entire journey is a long slog from
beginning to end
and you wouldn't be blamed for wanting
to give up halfway through
one of the all-time classic comedies
bill and ted's excellent adventure
follows the long strange journey of high
school slackers bill s
preston and theodore ted logan their
high school slackers struggling to pass
their upcoming history test
and even worse ted's father is making
plans to ship him off to military
school if he can't earn a decent grade
of course doing that would alter the
course of the future
as these two are destined to save all of
humanity with their rock and roll music
so rufus a citizen of the future travels
back to the past to help them ace their
test
as a result the heroic duo ends up going
on a time traveling adventure enlisting
familiar historical figures to help them
pass their test
it's a fantastic premise and even though
it's one of his earliest films reeves is
absolutely fantastic proving he's a more
than capable comedy
actor of course if you need more bill
and ted in your life never fear
excellent adventure inspired two more
sequels bogus journey and base the music
and who doesn't need a little more bill
and ted in their lives
excellent
and exposed reeves plays detective scott
galbin a man who's trying to uncover the
mystery behind the shocking death of his
corrupt partner detective joey cullen
however cullen's colleagues worry that
digging into his past will result in bad
pr for the police department
things get even stranger when galvin
realizes that a young woman named isabel
with seemingly no prior connection to
cullen might be involved with the case
somehow
unfortunately exposed was pretty much
doomed from the get-go
the film was originally titled daughter
of god and the plot was supposed to
focus predominantly on isabelle and her
family but the studio behind the movie
decided that centering the storyline
around reeves character would result in
higher returns at the box office
the film went through a number of
substantial changes in post-production
resulting in a very different movie than
the one the director had initially
planned
it's clear that this was a misstep in
the end and it's a real shame that the
original narrative never saw the light
of day
my own private idaho stands out from the
rest of risa's earlier work in hollywood
it's loosely based on a series of
shakespeare plays but director gus van
sant adapted the bard's classic tale
into a thoroughly modern story
even now it's regarded as a classic
example of new queer cinema
and while the subject matter wouldn't be
viewed as particularly taboo today
it definitely pushed boundaries back in
the early 1990s the film was also
notable for its creative avant-garde
visual style
as for the plot reeves and his real-life
friend river phoenix co-stars the
wandering protagonist scott
mike these two friends work as street
hustlers in portland but when mike
decides that he desperately needs to
find his mother they set off on a
journey that takes him all the way to
italy
mike finds himself falling for scott and
the two have to navigate the intense
emotions tied up in their complicated
relationship
as a result the film is very different
from reeves more action-heavy movies but
it proved to a skeptical world that the
actor really did have some serious
dramatic chops
replicas was universally panned by
critics and it wasn't much of a hit with
audiences either to be fair to reeves
though he was probably the only bright
spot in this practically unwatchable
film
but try as he might his performance just
couldn't salvage this truly dire movie
reeves plays william foster a
neuroscientist who ventures into some
pretty unethical territory while caught
in the throes of grief
after his wife and children die in a car
crash she decides to try cloning them
he knows he has to keep this experiment
a secret but he can't hide it forever
and naturally this risky decision comes
with some unintended consequences
admittedly the idea behind replicas is
actually quite interesting and with
better execution this could have been a
far more engaging film
but with numerous plot holes and a cast
of characters who just can't seem to
stop themselves from making the worst
possible decision in every scenario
watching replicas becomes little more
than an exercise in frustration
speed was one of reeves first major
blockbuster films and was arguably the
movie that catapulted him to superstar
status
reeve stars is jack traven a swat
officer working with the lapd
jack and his partner think they've
managed to stop extortionist bomber
howard payne after he attempted to hold
a group of elevator passengers for
ransom
as it turns out however payne is also
rigged a bus with a bomb
and if the vehicle's speed drops below
50 miles per hour it will explode and
kill
everyone on board now it's up to jack to
defuse the explosive and get everyone to
safety
admittedly the premise of speed comes
across as kind of silly but as the movie
picks up it's nearly impossible to look
away from the screen
the genuinely sizzling on-screen
chemistry between reeves and his co-star
sandra bullock certainly didn't hurt
either
and then of course there's the bus jump
one of hollywood's best ever driving
stunts
and it was totally real too
all in all this is reeves at his 90s
best just don't mention the sequel
based on a william gibson story of the
same name johnny mnemonic sees reeve
star as its titular character
the plot is clever enough johnny has a
cybernetic brain
implant that can store all kinds of
information and in a dystopian society
ruled by megacorporations where everyone
is forced to be connected to the
internet his abilities come in very
handy indeed
in johnny's world transmitting sensitive
data can be dangerous
so as a mnemonic courier it's up to him
to carry certain information to
different parties
however doing so means risking losing
his childhood memories
and he wants to remove his implant to
get them back unfortunately for johnny
however his work isn't quite done yet
johnny mnemonic didn't exactly get a
glowing response from the critics
in fact reeves actually earned himself a
razzy nomination for worst actor so it's
safe to say that this role was
a new low point in his career although
it was marketed as an exciting
cyberpunk thriller the plot falls
totally flat and worse still it is aged
very badly indeed
even for a 90s film sadly there's just
nothing all that memorable about the
futuristic
world of johnny mnemonic the matrix was
more than just a film
it was a cultural phenomenon the movie
won four academy awards and left a
lasting impact on an entire generation
of filmmakers
and while reeves was already a
well-known actor when the matrix was
released
this film brought his career to a whole
new level in this masterpiece from the
wachowski sisters reeve stars as neo a
hacker who's unknowingly living in a
dystopia where humanity has been trapped
in a simulated reality called the matrix
this simulation was designed by machines
so they could control human beings by
keeping them in pods all while
harvesting their bodies for energy
when neo discovers the truth about his
world he's given a choice
he can take the blue pill and return to
his old life or he can take the red pill
and finally accept reality
and even though he knows he can never
truly go back neo nonetheless steps up
to lead the rebellion against the
machines
the resulting movie is full to the brim
with philosophical musings incredible
martial arts fights and some of the most
recognizable and iconic quotes in
cinematic history
i know kung fu
show me the matrix also gave audiences a
truly classic villain and agent smith
gifted film fans with one of the coolest
opening scenes ever plus one of cinema's
craziest gun fights
the movie revolutionized hollywood with
its innovative camera work and brought
newfound fame and respect to reeves
himself who delivered a fascinating
zen-like performance
honestly the matrix isn't just one of
keanu reeves greatest films it's one of
the greatest science fiction films of
all time
generation um however might just be the
worst out of reeves entire career
even the title is underwhelming and
things don't exactly improve from there
this mumble core indie flick was so
unwatchable that it actually managed to
score a whopping zero percent on rotten
tomatoes
in generation um reeves plays john an
escort service driver who's lost all
sense of direction in life the film
explores 24 hours of his aimless
existence in new york city in which he
meets up with two young women violet and
mia
this is an attempt to delve into the
concept of urban alienation but the
movie falls far
short of its attention in one scene for
example jon points a camcorder at the
women and asks them to say something
interesting
neither offers up anything particularly
poignant and that basically sums up the
film as a whole
in the end this movie is basically a
shrug of the shoulders
and it quickly comes to the tired
conclusion that young people these days
just might be a little vain and
self-absorbed
not exactly revolutionary stuff is it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one